if you're looking for a maxi power bank
to charge your phone without having a
cable dangling down there are now
thankfully lots of options to choose
from but unfortunately most are
rebranded products from china with
exaggerated misleading specs and fake
reviews so i decided to buy four of the
most popular or interesting ones and put
them head to head in every test that
matters so we'll be going over all of
that including how fast they will charge
and how much you'll actually get from
each one and at the end i will tell you
which one you should buy now i really
wanted to include anker's power core
magnetic power bank but unfortunately
they keep pushing back the shipping date
so i couldn't include it but based on
info that i gathered from reviews
compared to these ones i wouldn't buy
the anchor anyway and i'll explain why i
have links to all of these down in the
video description and since all but the
hyper power can be purchased under a
variety of names i will be making up my
own name so you guys can easily follow
along and know which one is which in
these tests let's start out with big
gray at 35
this is the only one that advertises 10
000 milliamp hours of capacity even
though it's almost the same as the
previous 5 000 milliamp hour that i
showed off so we'll see how much it
actually has this thing feels super
solid in the hand and has a raised
rubber pad and alignment magnet which
provides a fairly strong connection that
doesn't easily twist we have a power
button to turn on the charging and a set
of led lights to show a battery life and
a usbc port for two-way charging just
like each power bank that i tested with
that big gray is the only one that also
has a usb type a port which can be handy
if you only have an older usb cable to
use and it can actually power three
devices at once and not only that you
can also use it to replace a wireless
charger since it can charge your phone
and itself at the same time and then you
can just take it with you as you need
which three of these four power banks
can actually do the next one i named
kickstand since it's the only one with a
kickstand so you can prop it up while
it's attached and charging your phone
it's 34 bucks and it is thinner than big
gray but also taller so it ends up
having the biggest footprint overall and
since it sits flush with your phone it's
the only one that won't properly work
with the 12 mini kickstand has a second
trick that no other magnetic power bank
has and that is a lightning port in
addition to usb type-c which can be used
to charge the power bank but not your
phone it's rated at 5 000 milliamp hours
rating just like the next one the hyper
power and also the anchor it also has by
far the strongest magnet which is almost
too strong but unfortunately since the
bottom uses a really slick plastic
material it constantly twists on the
body which is super annoying to me since
it never really sits straight and with
the iphone 12 it rubs against the camera
bump causing plastic to literally be
shaved off the whole thing feels cheap
and the kickstand is flimsy so it seems
like it won't last very long and it will
end up breaking off the next one is the
only one that doesn't just get rebranded
and sold the hyper power it's 40 bucks
and definitely seems like a brand name
product based on the design and the
quality plastic that is used it is on
the smaller side but it's definitely
thick and the bottom is a softer plastic
but not rubbery hyperpower does have an
alignment magnet but it's not very
strong so it's easy to twist the power
bank and in general this one has the
weakest magnet overall so sometimes you
drop it in your pocket and it will
actually detach from your phone and stop
charging which the other ones don't do
and our last one is blue mini which is
by far the smallest one being just as
thin as kickstand but with a tiny
footprint which works perfectly for the
iphone 12 mini not only that but it's
the cheapest one as well at only 27 and
the only one with a fully really grippy
rubber back so it is very resistant to
twisting and even though it's by far the
smallest one out of the group its magnet
is actually the second strongest which
was surprising now i was also surprised
about the battery rating which is just
slightly less than the previous two at 4
200 milliamp hours but we'll see if it's
actually that high
and it's also the only one that can't
pass through wireless charging along
with that the blue mini accepts the most
actual power when charging at 16.7 watts
and because the battery is the smallest
it will charge very quickly big gray and
kickstand both accept 16.4 watts so just
slightly less but of course kickstand
can also accept power through the
lightning port which maxes out at 9.7
real world watts so don't use that if
you want to charge it fast the slowest
max 8 power bank is the only one with
the brand name hyper at 10 real world
watts through usb type c so we'll take
the longest to charge up and with that
if you want to charge an iphone from the
usb type c port it is also the slowest
at only 8 watts for some reason the rest
of the power banks output 10.4 watts to
an iphone and the only one with the usb
type-a ports can pass through 4.8 watts
that way now one thing that really gets
to me is a ton of these brands advertise
up to 15 watts of wireless charging
through magsafe well that's simply not
true because an iphone can only accept
7.5 watts if you're not using the
official max safe charger so i decided
to test what they actually get through
its magnetic coils let's start out with
the most disappointing one the blue mini
even though it accepts the most power
through usb type c for charging it only
outputs about three and a half watts
after efficiency loss which means it's
most likely based on 5 watts for
wireless charging and that's also what
anker's is rated big ray showed 6 watts
which is better and hyper and kickstand
showed 7 watts which is likely based on
7.5 watt qi charging now of course
wattage can vary as you go on so let's
take a look at what is actually our
charging time and how much each phone
gets charged with these power banks for
all of my testing i use an iphone 12
which is by far the most popular new
iphone but the 12 pro should charge
exactly the same since it has the same
battery and i'll also comment on the 12
mini and 12 pro max in just a bit i made
sure that the iphone 12 was completely
drained and attached each battery to see
how long they would take to turn on your
phone which is always such a frustrating
weight big grade took 4 minutes and 20
seconds to start the phone kickstand
took a much longer 6 minutes hyper was
the quickest at only 3 minutes and 15
seconds and blue mini took 5 minutes and
30 seconds after 15 minutes blue mini
only hit six percent charge which was
disappointing after 15 minutes of
waiting big gray managed nine percent
which is right in line with my desktop
qii chargers and surprisingly hyper and
kickstand charged at double blue mini's
rate at 12 after 15 minutes at the 30
minute mark all chargers about double
their charge rate with the blue mini
hitting 13
which the other two pretty much hit in
the first 15. let's skip 45 minutes and
jump right to the one hour mark hyper
and kickstand both reach the same 42
percent which isn't impressive but it's
still faster than my desktop g chargers
which reached the same speed at big
great at 35 percent and blue mini is
slightly behind at 28
and jumping to the one and a half hour
mark which is where wired fast charging
would have fully charged the iphone 12
our two faster chargers hit 60 percent
big ray hit 53 and blue mini a sad 42
and after two to two and a half hours
some chargers started to drastically
slow down while others like the blue
mini and hyper completely ran out of
power
blue mini ended up only charging the
iphone 12 to 68
whereas hyper reached 85 in the same
time kickstand slowed but kept going for
another half hour where it died after
reaching 95 percent and big gray kind of
stalled between two and a half to three
hours staying at around 80 percent even
though optimized charging was turned off
and then it sped up slightly and kept
going until the four hour mark where it
fully charged our iphone 12 being the
only one to hit 100
but not only that it was still showing
charge so i drained my iphone 12 for the
fifth time and believe it or not it
ended up charging it another 50
where the others couldn't even do 100
once now the question is does it
actually have ten thousand milliamp
hours of capacity like the listing well
i'm not so sure especially since the
listing also shows somewhere around
seven thousand milliamp hours as a side
note at the bottom so i went ahead and i
took the percentage of charge from each
power bank and i divided that
based on the milliamp hours that the
iphone 12's battery is listed at and
that gave me a real-world charge of 4
200 milliamp hours once we account for
loss due to heat and other factors
kickstand provided 2675 in hyper 2400
and blue mini only 1915 milliamp hours
meaning it wouldn't even fully charge an
iphone 12 mini so based on the test
results you would think that big rate is
probably the one to buy since it can
actually charge your phone all the way
it has pass-through charging and
multiple outputs as well and has a
decent magnetic connection and you may
be right but for me it is my number two
choice that is because it is definitely
by far the heaviest and chunkiest one
and it's also fairly slow so if you're
planning to charge your phone while
using it it's not going to be very
comfortable for long and after a while
your hand is just going to get tired and
heavy so personally i'm not really a fan
of that since it's just way too heavy to
use this way and even though the blue
mini has the least amount of features
and it's by far the slowest it is
actually my favorite because of how
small it is and how lightweight it is i
can easily keep it on my phone while
using it as it doesn't add much bulk and
it doesn't slip off so i use it to keep
my battery from draining and it slowly
tops it off as well now personally i'm
not a fan of the other two even though
they charge fast because they come off
way too easily and they're not very
comfortable while using it and with that
they also don't give you a full charge
and the same thing goes for anchor's
battery bank based on all the reviews
that i read but you guys let me know
what you think down below in the comment
section which charger would fit your
personal needs better and why i will
have all the link down below in the
description for you guys to check out
the prices at the time that you're
watching the video and if you guys
enjoyed it go ahead and click that
circle above to subscribe and check out
one of the other great videos right over
there this has been max and i'll see you
in the next video
[Music]
you